[موسيقى]
الاربعاء الثامن من يناير 2020
اجتهدف الصواريخ الحارثي الثوري الايراني
طائره تابعه للخطوط الجويه الاوكرانيه
و 179 راكبا كانوا على متن تلك الطائره
بعد وقت قصير من اقلاعها اسقط الحرس
الثوري الايراني الطائره تلك الرحله في
اول موقف رسمي انكر السلطات الطيران
الايرانيه اصابه الطائره وعزت حادثه
التحطم الى خطا التقني فيما اوضحت السلطات
الاوكرانيه بعد مو سيارتها في البدايه الى
التفسير الايراني ان اسقاط الطائره بصاروخ
كان احدا نظريات الرئيسيه التي تعمل عليها
اما المسؤولون الامريكيون والكنديون
والبريطانيون فقد صرحوا ان الطائره قد تم
اسقاطها بواسطه الصاروخ ارض جو ايراني
بعدها اقر فيلق الحارس الثوري بانهم اسقط
الطائره بعد ان اعتقد خطا بانها صاروخ
كروز امريكي
ثلاث سنوات مرت على جريمه لا تزال
اصدقائها تتردد جريمه قتل فيها من قتل
فيما لا يزال مرتكبها بعيدا عن يد القانون
الدولي اما اهالي الضحايا فما بيدهم حيله
سوا دعوات الاحتجاج او الاضراب عصام عبد
السلام العربيه